[Music]
according to the scrum guide scrum is a
framework for developing delivering and
sustaining complex products scrum is a
collection of roles events artifacts and
rules that help teams work together more
effectively and harmoniously it's been
in wide use for over 20 years in a
variety of industries ranging from
software development where it is best
known to harbor development marketing
and even nonprofits because scrum is
highly compatible with the agile values
and principles practitioners considered
to be an agile framework along with lean
Kanban XP and many others so let's start
with our company's vision our mission
this is why we show up to work every day
right if you're in a bigger company you
might have multiple products each with
their own vision either way you've got a
sense of where you want your company or
product to be over the course of the
next one to three years or so personally
I think it's useful to write visions
from your customers perspective one
company vision statement that I really
like is Amazon's our vision is to be
earth's most customer centric company to
build a place where people can come to
find and discover anything they might
want to buy online
compare this to a vision statement like
were the biggest online retailer in the
world another way of thinking of it is
this your vision statement reflects your
big impact on the world the value that
we wouldn't have if your company didn't
exist to use Steve's jobs terminology
it's your dent in the universe your
vision should be succinctly stated right
size and scope and realistic enough
given your current and likely future
capabilities visions help us understand
the strategy while having a roadmap
helps us understand or tack
and desire timing while a vision helps
us understand where we want to be in a
few years a world map projects what will
we be doing over the next three to four
quarters but either way your roadmap is
still just a wish list basically
information that you have available to
you now it will almost certainly change
over the course of the next several
months if it doesn't this should be a
huge red flag that you're not
incorporating enough feedback from your
users quickly enough one of the biggest
ways a technology company creates
positive user outcomes is to output
reliable working software notice there's
a difference between output and outcomes
you probably need some working software
to get positive outcomes for your users
but there's no guarantee that a
particular set of outputs will produce
the desired outcomes working software is
just half the battle if you want to keep
building working software quickly in the
future and keep your customers happy
you're going to need to make sure you've
built the software well agile teams use
a definition of done to help them
determine whether or not their software
meets their quality bar it's a
documented team agreement that specifies
the conditions that must be met such as
automated testing and scalability before
the team calls a piece of work done
isn't done this helps protect the team
from building up costly technical debt
okay so over what time horizon two teams
do work scrum teams complete work in one
to four week cycle is known as
iterations or sprints the team expects
to create a done demonstrable and
potentially shippable product increment
based on my experience coaching dozens
of teams I now suggest one to two weeks
Sprint's three to four week Sprint's
don't allow teams to iterate quickly
enough and allow for nasty anti patterns
to creep in what work will they complete
in that sprint the team will refer to a
sprint backlog
prioritize lists of the most valuable
work that is ready for the team to work
on now the team doesn't strictly
guarantee they'll they'll get all of
this work done it's just a forecast
healthy team should be able to fully
complete somewhere between 85 percent
and a hundred and fifteen percent of
what they planned on let's take a moment
for an important discussion why do we
say that this is a forecast instead of a
commitment it turns out that the
official scrum guide used to say
commitment but they change it in 2011
because quote reality keeps on showing
us that it is difficult if not
impossible to always fulfill this
self-imposed commitment without making
compromises to quality on the other hand
the chosen alternative forecast has to
do with making assumptions based on
reliable information and evidence this
is much closer to how an experienced
scrum team works that said the team
should feel comfortable committing to
the Sprint goal which would be written
in such a way that it can be
accomplished even if not all the items
in the sprint backlog are completed
where does a team get the work for the
Sprint backlog they get it from the
product backlog a prioritized list of
work that the team intends to work on
from now to the medium term future
product backlogs contain every piece of
work your team plans to work on work
that you plan to do in the next sprint
or two will be granular and captured
with detailed acceptance criteria while
work that you don't plan on doing for
another several months will be less
granular it should have just highlights
of what you hope to accomplish by the
way the official scrum guide calls us a
product backlog but I think team backlog
is more accurate this is because a
single team may be working on multiple
products but should only work from one
backlog notice how some of the work on
your product backlog will be ready to
work on while some isn't how do we
prevent items from making it onto the
sprint backlog before they're ready
we use a definition of ready a document
a team agreement that specifies the
conditions that must be met such as
being the right size and having clearly
articulated acceptance criteria the team
understands before the team pulls the
item into the sprint backlog so who are
all the people doing all of this work
first we have the product owner they are
responsible for maximizing the outcomes
and impact from any given set of output
that a team might produce what this
means is that two development teams may
write the same amount of software but
the saucier that one team produces could
be far more valuable to users that team
probably had a more experienced and
empowered product owner this individual
has an incredibly important role and
they need to be fully enabled by their
organization to set the product
direction in a nutshell the product
owner is responsible for what and why
what we're building and why we're
building it next we have the entire
cross-functional development team some
companies think that just software
developers blame belong in the
development team but I think that's
short-sighted I found that teams are far
more functional when a wider breadth of
skillsets such as user experience
Quality Assurance and operations are
also on the team just as product owners
must be empowered to decide what to work
on the development team must be
empowered to determine how and when how
we will meet the desire to use your
outcomes and when it will be potentially
releasable you've probably figured out
that the product owner has a need for
speed while the development team has a
real need for quality they're both right
who keeps all this in balance that's
right the scrum master the scrum master
is responsible for coaching both the
product owner and the development team
on effective scrum they teach and
reinforce scrums
values principles and practices they are
a servant leader for the product owner
development team and broader
organization so how do we make work
ready to work on once or twice a week
the whole team gets together product
owner scrum master and development team
and reviews and refines the product
backlog together we call this event
backlog refinement though some people
might refer to it as backlog grooming
although this isn't an official scrum
event I see it in most implementations
the product owner brings up user stories
and begins a clarifying conversation
with the team to improve the quality of
each user story for instance suppose the
product owner says that they would like
a cup of hot coffee a member of the
development team might ask how hot is
hot after a brief conversation they'll
decide on a more objective measurement
of temperature and update the user story
our goal will be had to have one and a
half to two Sprint's worth of ready
stories by the time we start our next
sprint the Sprint itself begins with
sprint planning the purpose of sprint
planning is to a determine what can be
most likely to delivered in the next
sprint and be come up with a high-level
plan for how that work will be
accomplished only the development team
can decide what it can accomplish over
the upcoming sprint they will do this by
considering the work completed and left
incomplete from the prior sprint the
team's capacity at this sprint and the
team's historical performance teams
often overcome it either due to pressure
from the product owner or naive optimism
the scrum master will discourage this
with effective coaching having
determined a reasonable sprint backlog
the development team decides together
how we'll complete the work this sprint
most teams decomposed user stories bugs
and other product backlog items into
more granular tasks generally taking a
day or less this is effective because
the high-level design of the software
occurs in a high bandwidth facilitated
event with all subject matter experts
present now the team has kicked off
their sprint they will check in with
each other
every day in an event called the daily
scrum or daily stand-up this is a 15
minute time box event that allows a
development team to synchronize their
work and plan for the next 24 hours
it's how the same time in place every
day during the daily scrum each
development team member typically
answers three questions what did I you
yesterday that will help our team meet
our sprint goal what will I do today
that will help our team meet our
sprinkle and do I see any impediments or
blockers that will prevent me or the
team from meeting our sprinkle many
teens will also use this opportunity to
review the quantity of remaining work
and come up with a mitigation strategy
if the team isn't on track to meet their
sprint goal at the end of the Sprint the
team will demonstrate their work to
customers and other stakeholders and an
event called Sprint review or the Sprint
demo at a minimum the team will
demonstrate completed work solicit
feedback and answer questions teams will
also often discuss the current product
backlog recent developments that may
justify a plan change and any notable
metrics finally this break concludes
with a retrospective this is when the
whole team inspects his own performance
and creates an improvement plan for the
next sprint it occurs after the review
and before the next Sprint planning
event together the team will inspect how
the Sprint went in terms of team culture
structure processes and tools from there
it can identify major opportunities to
persist what went well and change what
didn't lastly the team will come up with
a plan for continued self-improvement
usually through actions experiments or
changes in team behavior for the next
sprint now there's a few rules that
aren't part of official scrum but we can
find them in nearly every organization
first we have our stakeholders they are
in
our best proxy for an customers and
users it's tempting for a stakeholder to
attempt to exert undue influence over
the team to prioritize their specific
request some companies might even create
incentive structures that don't reflect
reality such as having several
stakeholders whose bonuses all depend on
getting a feature shipped this quarter
even if the team can deliver only one a
good product owner can effectively work
through conflicts between stakeholders
and create a roadmap in team backlog
that maximizes value for the whole
company next we have our managers
everyone from engineering managers to
product directors as teams move to
becoming highly autonomous and
self-organizing to describe the
traditional command and control role of
managers must be abandoned in favour of
true servant leadership this change can
be extremely difficult for many managers
in fact it requires a much greater
degree of psychosocial maturity and
emotional intelligence a skillful agile
coach or scrum master if empowered can
help managers make this transition which
leaves us last with our executives which
covers almost everyone with a chief role
as well as everyone on the board
these individuals are far and away the
single greatest factor and whether or
not any agile transformation will be
successful they define the company's
culture through the behavior that they
exhibit and promote literally a leader
such as an engineering manager cannot
create safety and autonomy for their
teams if they do not feel safe under
their leaders as well if we promote a
manager with a habit of barking command
to control orders all the feel-good
culture events and posters won't foster
development of true servant leadership
so we talked about the fundamental roles
artifacts and events that you'll find in
an organization as practicing scrum well
what's the end result let's suppose we
create the right culture build an
effective organizational structure and
let teams to find the processes and
tools that work best for them
after practicing textbook scrum long
enough to fully internalize it what do
we get we create an environment where
everyone feels empowered to creatively
solve the problems thanks for listening
[Music]